okay bunch of topics to cover before we
wrap things up for the week and get
right get ready for the fourth of July
remember as we head into the fourth of
July that it's important to keep in mind
the top three most overrated
fourth of July activities are fireworks
parades and sparklers now I have kids so
my for July is gonna be consumed by all
three of those awful things but if you
can't escape it then I would fight you
know there are more worthwhile ways to
spend your time on a holiday like
drinking and eating you know do more
that the thing with them of course of as
I've said before with parades a parade
is just a festive traffic jam you're
just basically watching a traffic jam
with some of the vehicles you know with
dressed up in interesting ways
fireworks are fun to watch for about
three minutes I've never seen a
fireworks display that could hold my
attention for more than three minutes
because you know you see the first
firework that was great in the second
firework and say oh did you see that one
well of course I saw it I'm sitting in
the you know in in the dark and there's
explosions of course I saw it yeah it
was it was it was good then another one
oh yeah okay good nice I think after
that third one though it's kind of like
okay I get it I mean I get the point
I understand what you're doing here
Explosions in the Sky greates can't we
go home now so that's that's what it is
with fireworks I would just have more
creativity this this weekend think of
more think more creative things to do
with your time speaking of the fourth of
July I want to begin with this Colin
Kaepernick thing we talked about it
briefly yesterday just to recap Nike
recalled a patriotic American flag shoe
after Colin Kaepernick who they're
paying hundreds of millions of dollars
to as a sponsor even though he's not an
athlete doesn't do anything anymore
these days after he complained and he
said I didn't like it now this is this
is obviously so self-evidently absurd
and disgraceful such a cowardly
surrender to political correctness that
there's not a lot that can be said about
it Colin Kaepernick
we felt that the flag which is a Betsy
Ross flag from the American Revolution
he thought that it somehow represents
slavery's as I pointed out yesterday
well if that's the case then every
pretty much every flag in the world
represents slavery at least every flag
of every country 200 years old or older
represents slavery because they all had
slaves but the one notable thing about
this which is not very surprising but at
least it does kind of reveal the truth
is that it we finally see that Colin
Kaepernick's kneeling stunt has all
along been actually about the flag it's
been about it's been about hating the
flag and about hating America we were
told for years that it wasn't about that
we were told that the kneelers were not
protesting the flag or the country or
the national anthem
there was this viral tweet I don't know
if you ever saw it got like 300,000
likes on Twitter last year and it kind
of summed up this defense and said Rosa
Parks was not protesting the bus Gandhi
was not protesting the food the
colonists were not protesting t players
are not protesting the flag or the
anthem they are protesting injustice
okay that and that's the that's a
protest of injustice that's the slogan
we kept hearing the media setted LeBron
James is one of the highest profile
defenders of the anthem protests he said
the same thing kyle colin kaepernick who
started it all said that he was trying
to call attention to injustice also to
what he calls police violence but it
wasn't about the flag they said in case
anyone was actually fooled by that now
we know it was indeed about the flag it
was always about the flag because now he
doesn't want the flag on the shoe so
that that can't be about injustice
that's just about that he doesn't like
the flag colin kaepernick does not like
this country that much is pretty clear
by now he's rich and famous and he's
free and those are all things that he
probably would not be if he lived in any
number of other countries but his
privilege has made him bitter and he's
free to be bitter and he's free to hate
this country but I think he should be
honest about where he stands or kneels
as the
case maybe now I wanted to make one
other point about this we all week
that's all the stuff that we talked
about yesterday one of the and I've seen
this again online the last couple days
over this shoe thing one of the sort of
cliched responses to this kind of issue
especially with respect to Kaepernick is
to say hey but if you don't like America
you can get out right on South Park did
a whole episode about the back when
South Park was funny they did an episode
about that and it does at this point
sounds sort of corny and cliche to say
it and oftentimes people are wrong when
they say it oftentimes somebody will
simply criticize American culture or
American government or the laws or
whatever and then someone will respond
with a get out line but see it doesn't
work there because why should I leave
this country just because I I think the
culture of government can be improved
maybe I want to stay here and improve it
so there's nothing something unpatriotic
about criticizing the country in and of
itself
nothing unpatriotic about that and in
fact to insist that you can't criticize
the country is itself unpatriotic
because that's one of the things that
sets us apart is that you can get up
there and say basically whatever you
want at least as it stands right now
although it's probably changing as it
stands right now you can get up in
public and basically say whatever you
want about the state of things and offer
your criticism that's what set us apart
is a perfectly patriotic thing to do I
think it was a it was either Chesterton
or Lewis who's who made the point that
you know it's it's not unpatriotic to
criticize the country just like it
wouldn't be unloving for you to warn
your mother that she's about to wander
over the edge of a cliff it would
actually be unloving if you did it so in
the same way if you love this country
you are going to criticize the things
about it that are actually bad but I do
think the get-out response is
appropriate sometimes even if it's
cliched there's truth to it and I think
that's the case with the Kapernick thing
and here's the difference because it
seems that Kaepernick and many other
leftist such as the ones who want to
tear down murals of George Washington
and and Jefferson it seems that their
beef is with America's it's what their
American is it's with America's current
situation yes but also with America's
past they think America is a
fundamentally racist country and then
it's past sins stain it and will always
stain it and that it's a country that
has no right to exist because the land
is stolen etc in other words they hate
America for things that cannot be
changed we can't change the past if you
hate America for things that can't be
changed then yeah you really should get
out you that that actually is the only
logical response and why wouldn't you
want to get out if that's how you feel
about it
it's like like I said the people who
can't get over the fact that this
country was supposedly built on stolen
land which of course by that logic every
country has no right to exist because
they're all built on stolen land quote
unquote the the borders of countries are
not generally established through
friendly discussion and it's been
especially they weren't established that
way in the past that's how that's how
the map looks the way it is now all
across the world it's through fighting
and dying and that's just that's the way
the world has worked there's an America
is not unique in that way just like
America is not unique with slavery but
if you really think that America has no
right to exist that the land is stolen
then why are you still here I think it's
a good question that I've never heard a
good answer to I would even say that
you're morally obligated to leave the
country if that's how you feel the
people say
I'm gonna be proud of this country we
stole the land it's fundamentally racist
there's built on slavery it's a we can't
check even if those things are all true
we can't change it there's there's
nothing we can do it's it's not like we
can all work together to make those
things Jane we can't go back into the
past we can't get into a time machine so
if you can't get over that if you hate
the country because of it if we can't
even celebrate our history because of it
if we can't have traditions and the real
culture because of it in your mind then
I think the only logical thing for you
to do is just to leave and go to another
country now like I said wherever you go
you're going to inevitably end up in an
area where there used to be slavery
maybe there still is depending on where
you go
where you know the land was
quote/unquote stolen I mean that's gonna
be the case wherever you go but yeah I
mean if you're if you're blaming America
if you're pointing America out is this
unique evil that you must not think that
you must not realize that that must not
be the way you see it you must think
that there are places in the world where
it's you know where they're not stained
by any of these things wherever it's all
perfect and well then go to one of those
places and I think that would work out
best for everybody it's it's the most
logical and the most moral response I
you know I personally people get upset
when you hear these celebrities or
whoever threatened to leave the country
I'm not upset by that by all means you
should leave I would actually have a lot
of respect for somebody like Colin
Kaepernick if he said you know I'm fed
up with this country I hate it so much
I'm gone I'm moving to wherever I have a
ton of respect to that I wouldn't agree
I would think that you suffer from the
extraordinary amount of historical
ignorant but I would at least respect
the follow-through and I would respect
it too because you would be making a
sacrifice because there are a lot of
privileges there's a lot of comfort in
this country that you're not going to
find in other countries and to give that
up in order to follow your convictions
even if they are somewhat twisted and
misguided Idris
like that but that's not what these
people do colin kaepernick remains in
this country living off the fat of the
land living off of the the the privilege
and comforts that have been established
in his mind established through
oppression and evil at everything then
he takes advantage of it
so he's way worse than any of the rest
of us to actually see it that way and
yet to stay here anyway because oh well
I'm rich that is I mean you'd have to be
some kind of sociopath all right
Democrat representative Frederica Wilson
is not a very smart person and when I
say that you might accuse me of making
fun of fredericka Wilson which I am but
according to Frederica Wilson I should
go to jail for making fun of her here's
what she had to say at a press
conference yesterday watch this people
making fun of members of Congress are
disgrace and there's no need for anyone
to think that is unacceptable we're
going to shut them down and work with
whoever it is to shut them back and they
should be prosecuted you cannot
intimidate members of Congress threat
not threaten members of Congress it is
against the law and it's a shame in this
United States of America okay a few
things here number one this woman has
not to continue making fun of her
especially if it's illegal but this
woman has the most annoying voice I have
ever heard in my life hands down she
sounds like a cartoon character and she
wears the Hat of a count cartoon
character either also and she says that
people who make fun of members of
Congress should be prosecuted so she is
very explicitly coming out against the
First Amendment just so we're clear
about what's going on here
that's she she doesn't believe in the
First Amendment she wants she wants us
to repeal it basically because you would
have to repeal it in order to make it
illegal to make fun of members of
Congress especially when the First
Amendment
exists in large part for specifically
that to to criticize make fun of
whatever people in power that's why we
need the first amendment so she's saying
no let's get rid of it
and she says but she says if I if I
heard correctly she says when referring
to people making fun of Congress members
she said there is there is no need to
think that it is unacceptable so what
does that mean there's no need to think
that it's unacceptable she's saying that
it isn't acceptable but she says there's
no need to think that it's unacceptable
which means that it is acceptable I I'm
just this woman is babbling incoherently
maybe what she meant to say is there's
no need to think period that is
unacceptable maybe that's what you meant
there's no need to think period end of
sentence that is unacceptable it's
unacceptable to think in other words I
think maybe that's what she was trying
to say which if it is unacceptable to
think then at least Frederick Wilson is
safe from any criticism in that regard
all right I said we're gonna we're gonna
blow through them today try to get
through as many as we can
Tucker Carlson did a great segment
yesterday and I want to play that
segment for you but before we do backing
up just to give context here there has
been a controversy these past few days
over an alleged birtherism movement that
has supposedly popped up around Camilla
Harris people are claiming that Camilla
Harris is not a real african-american
because she's actually half Jamaican and
half Indian which she is so it's true
it's it's true she's not
african-american
she's Jamaica is not Africa India is not
Africa so she's not African and that's
simply a true statement it's not a
conspiracy theory now the whole
birtherism refers originally to the idea
that Barack Obama is is not a either not
a natural-born citizen or not a citizen
at all depending on who you
- that was a conspiracy theory it was
also untrue he he was a natural-born
citizen but this is true so it's not a
conspiracy theory it's just she's not
it's not an insult it's not racist it's
just a true fact that's all now this
whole thing started with a tweet a tweet
from a guy named ali alexander who after
the debate last week tweeted and said
Camilla Harris is not an American black
she has half Indian and half Jamaican
I'm so sick of people robbing American
blacks like myself of our history
it's disgusting now using it for debate
time at dem debate these are my people
not her people freaking disgusting then
later he tweeted your family does not
descend from American black slaves stop
appropriating our history it's why you
have to remain vague lest your voters
find you and your family history out
okay now if you caught it there this man
himself is black he is african-american
so this began with a black guy saying
she's not really one of us she's a
different ethnicity different race which
is fine okay now when I'm reading alex'
in alley Alexander's tweet I don't read
that he's criticizing her race or
something or that he's saying anything
racist he's just saying in from his
perspective it seems to him that she is
either explicitly or implicitly trying
to as he says appropriate an identity
that doesn't belong to her so given the
fact that he's african-american to say
that this is a racist thing with Kamala
Harris is absurd it started with a black
man he's the one at the forefront here
now the media doesn't want you to know
that Ali Alexander is black and they
really don't want you to know and to
understand just how much they really
don't want you to watch this from Wolf
Blitzer on CNN Donald Trump jr. he
deleted a post a tweet that he had over
the Wii
again he deleted this the message
somebody else wrote Camilla Harris is
not an American black she's half Indian
half Jamaican Donald Trump jr. added on
top of that retweet is this true
Wow and then he went ahead and deleted
that Camilla Harris is a mother was from
India father was from Jamaica I don't
know if you noticed that it was a little
bit subtle they showed the screenshot of
Trump juniors tweet and which is
apparently controversial but did you
notice something strange about the
screenshot in the screenshot you see
Trump's retweet of Ali Alexander but
what's missing from it
Ali Alexander's photo is not in them now
if you go and you retweet someone on
Twitter
you're gonna you're going to be
retweeting their the texts that are
tweet along with their profile picture
their avatar right um CNN took the time
apparently to go in and edit it remove
Ali Alexander's face from the tweet so
that nobody would know that it was a
black guy who originally said this so
really when when when Don junior
retweeted that he was simply agreeing
with or not even agreeing just sort of
reacting to something that a black guy
had said about Camilla Harris they don't
want you to know that because then it's
harder to paint Donald Trump jr. as a as
a racist so they removed his his photo
that's I mean that is remarkable really
I know we're used to these underhanded
deceptive tactics especially by CNN but
that goes several steps beyond what we
usually see but it gets worse than that
for CNN the people who are saying is she
blacking up that's bull that's BS but
200 to 2,000 to say is she
african-american or is she black or she
whatever that what's there is nothing
wrong with it all she had to do was say
I am black I'm not african-american
that's it when she goes down her lineage
many Africans landed on gin Jame
in all these other Caribbean islands so
she could induce with other words but
she is not America but she is so there
you go I see they dong first of all is
it really Don Lemon I thought it was Don
Lemon I've been taking Don lemons is it
really Lomond
Don Lemon how did it or is that just
something Tucker Carlson I don't know I
know I got you I really don't watch CNN
I just see these people's names written
so I always assumed it was Don Lemon
anyway I guess lemon sounds a little bit
classier I suppose but there it is
you've got LeMond slash lemon himself
making this point and this is a point
that you know I mean it goes without
saying but I'm gonna say it anyway if if
Camilla Harris was a Republican woman
same ethnicity Republican woman and a
black guy on the Left made this play by
Camille Harris you would be racist for
disagreeing with what the black I say
okay if if you switch the ideologies
around then then the racist thing would
be to not jump on the the birther
bandwagon to defend Kamala Harris would
be racist because then you'd be accused
of oh is what you're defending but so
you're claiming that being Jamaican and
being African America are the same thing
like it's a it's all the same you're a
racist you're a baby that's usually the
racist thing to point out the
distinction and say well Jamaica is not
Africa and it's not the same thing
that's the point II have the distinction
is usually the respectful thing and to
deny the distinction is racist but it's
been flipped around now because of the
because of the ideological makeup of the
situation all right let's check in with
the humorless feminist scolds an article
over on the website Eater written by
Jaya Saxena not sure that's her real
name or not deals with the scourge of of
restaurants making jokes on their menus
the the headline is
my girlfriend isn't hungry menu items
are thinly veiled misogyny and you know
that when we're talking about thinly
veiled misogyny you know it's gonna be
good so let me read a little bit of this
article to you it says it's become a
trope that when a heterosexual couple is
out on a date the woman might say she's
not that hungry but proceed to eat some
of the man's food
it seems innocent enough but complaints
that these girlfriends must be pulling
one over on their boyfriends to snag
commitment-free nachos has proliferated
to a point where restaurants across the
country are offering dishes and menus
for the quote not hungry date mama D's a
Little Rock Arkansas is the latest
restaurant to go viral for the menu
addition the $4 25 cent my girlfriend is
not hungry special gives you the option
of adding extra fries wings or cheese
sticks to your already existing meal in
another light it would be a lovely way
to offer couples a way to split food on
the cheap but it's framed as a burden
the man on a date must endure for sex
later the ability to joke about her
appetite on social media okay nut first
of all nobody ever said anything about
sex that this person is throwing that in
there mama DS isn't the only restaurant
to offer such a deal restaurants in
Oregon and New York will double your
fries tangled Hickory in Wisconsin will
double your fries and add extra onion
rings I'm getting hungry right now
reading this one-night stands in Calgary
will double you'll double your fries and
add three honey biscuits for the girl
who just wants biscuits and fries for
dinner and the tips okay blah blah blah
the tipsy coyote in Scottsdale Arizona
has named their entire salad menu my
girlfriend's not hungry because no
straight man would deign to eat lettuce
which is which is kind of true actually
let's start with the acknowledgement
that it's not a crime to just want three
onion rings sometimes actually this kind
of a crime who would only want three
onion rings I understand not wanting
onion rings at all but if you're gonna
have a three I mean that's a no the idea
that your girlfriend is intentionally
lying to you about how much fried food
she wants is based in the men are from
Mars and Venus is complicated idea that
women are always being cool
about what they really mean and it's a
man's job to decipher it well that's
kind of true though I mean women are
often being mean with with women it's
always like well you know I didn't want
to tell you I want you to just know
right that's why men are always getting
in trouble because they do something
that the girl didn't want them to do but
the girl never said she didn't want the
guy to do it or they're not doing
something that the girl does want the
guy to do but the girl never told the
guy she wanted and then and then when
the guy points out why don't you just
tell me then the girl will say well I
just wanted you to know
and the reason out credit where it's due
to women here the reason why women
expect men to just sort of know
intuitively what they want or don't want
is that women do have that ability with
men so I am convinced that there are
times when my wife can literally read my
mind like she'll walk into a room and
just um you know let's say I'm I'm a
little annoyed about something or
something happened with whatever she'll
walk and she'll immediately sense it and
not only sense that I'm off or annoyed
or angry about something but she'll even
know what what it's about
right away so women have that ability
men don't and so that's the frustration
women expect men to be able to do that
we can't do that we don't have that
ability so most of the time if you want
us to know something if you want us to
do something you just gotta say it
that's all I mean it's really as simple
as that just say hey will you do this or
will you not do that anyway that's what
that's about back to the article
let's see but aside from the misogyny
there are many reasons why anyone might
snag some fries without ordering her own
maybe she can't afford it or understands
her partner can't afford two full orders
of fries and is trying to be nice about
it maybe she just really wants a salad
but because salads are great in their
own right and also one onion ring
because onion rings are also great maybe
like many women she struggles with
disordered eating because we live in a
society that asks asks women that women
be chill enough to scarf down pizza but
also
110 pounds at all times and she's stuck
in a damned if you do situation where
her date will judge her no matter what
she orders okay that's just not true
men are not going to judge women based
on what you order we don't answer that
we really don't care so when you're
sitting at the restaurant with your man
and you say what should I get the man
doesn't get whatever you want he really
doesn't care maybe if you're dating and
he's paying for it then he might care if
you order the most expensive thing on
the menu so maybe don't do that although
even if you do that he's not gonna he's
not gonna let you know he cares he'll
still pay for but that's the only thing
we care about really is the price that's
actually let me let me back up and
clarify the only thing we care when it
comes to ordering food is just the price
outside of that just get whatever you
want to get three chili dogs if there
are three dollars a piece
get as many get five of them if you want
and it doesn't matter really just
whatever you want it's totally fine
anyway I'm not gonna I could keep
reading this but I'm not gay you get the
idea I think I cannot imagine writing
like six paragraphs about a menu joke
but this is the kind of pettiness that
you find among feminists now do you know
where this joke comes from it comes from
reality
it comes from real life from lived
experience women do in fact often claim
they aren't hungry and then proceeded to
steal your food that's a thing it
happens and in fact the whole reason the
joke works is that it happens so often
that people can relate to it and that's
the problem with getting offended by a
joke if the joke works if you can
recognize it as a joke because people
are laughing then that means it's
probably true that's why it works jokes
that are based in unreality jokes that
have no truth to them don't aren't no
one's gonna laugh because it just
doesn't make any sense
so it's a joke does it tease women a
little bit is it giving women a little
bit of a hard time yeah sure fine women
are being teased it is women are if you
want to say it the butt of the joke in
in some respect and so what who cares
women can handle being teased they can
handle being the butt of the joke it's
it mean it's it's not a big deal most
women can some women can't feminists
cannot feminists cannot handle jokes
they can they they especially cannot
handle being the butt of the joke they
just can't deal with it
but that's all the more reason to tell
these jokes because I mean if someone
could take a joke then you should make
jokes about them if someone can't take a
joke that's all the more reason to make
jokes about them you know there is
something insidious here we talk about
how the left is ruining comedy and and
they are because they're making it so
that we can't joke about the realities
and idiosyncrasies of life and of each
other and the effect is is more than
just making restaurant menus more boring
the thing is the reason we like comedy
the reason we like watching a stand-up
you know do his thing give his act the
reason we like to joke about these
truths about each other at about life
and about our experience is that it's
unifying it brings us together it's kind
of a moment for all of us to look at
each other and recognize the absurdity
of everything and just laugh about it
and that's why we enjoy it so much the
joke that always gets the biggest laugh
from me is is if I'm watching a stand-up
or I'm just even I see some funny tweet
or something the jokes that for me get
the biggest laugh and I think for most
people get the biggest laugh is when
it's a joke about something some
personal quirk or whatever that I
thought was unique to me or when someone
makes a joke about another person or
group of people or they you know and and
I thought I was the only one who noticed
that and then I see this joke and that
will get the biggest laugh because
you're saying oh you know other people
experiences I didn't realize that I
didn't know other people experiences
other people thought like this and that
realization brings joy it's a good thing
you laugh you're happy about it I think
ultimately it makes you let feel less
alone I think that's what comedy does it
makes us feel like we're not as alone in
the world because there are other people
who
experience life the same way that we do
and have noticed it's like when you're
walking around and you see all this
absurdity happening and you're thinking
am I the only one to know this is this
like this doesn't make any sense over
here this is ridiculous over here this
is kind of stupid and you think you're
the only one you feel alone and then you
hear someone make a joke about it you
think oh I'm not alone okay so the joke
is not just funny but it's it's it's
encouraging in a way as well you know
I've been around cancer patients who
joke with each other telling very
sometimes very morbid dark jokes about
their situation and and that's that's
pretty common people in very rough
situations sad situations joking about
it as common why do they joke about it
because it makes things a little less
scary it makes things less lonely less
sad I think when you're sick there are a
lot of things about it that are terrible
the fear and the pain and everything but
there's it's also very lonely because
most of people around you are healthy
and they're running around and doing
their thing living they're physically
capable healthy lives and you just feel
alone when you're around someone else in
the same situation you kind of joke
about you now you feel less alone that's
what comedy is now you know it when I
talk about a joke on a menu it's a small
thing it's like that's not really what
I'm talking about just talking about
comedy in general and jokes in general
and what the left is doing that's the
point of humor and that's what the left
wants to take away and they want to take
away especially the morbid humor the
dark humor the so-called offensive humor
the so-called sexist humor the humor
that deals with race and ethnicity and
identity and all of those things but
those are the areas those are precisely
the areas where we need humor the most
we need that unifying force that thing
that tells us it's not as serious as we
thought I mean those are what the people
say oh well yeah you could tell joke but
I'd be never joke about race never joke
about the other gender it was exactly
the things we should joke about those
are that's that those are the funniest
jokes not because it's me nor you trying
to hurt anyone's feelings but just
because it it's just these are art we
all experience it
all right um so that's that's feminism
for you let's move on to emails Matt
wall show at gmail.com Matt well show
gmail.com this is from Maria says dear
Matt I have to disagree with your take
on mini AOC though I agree that her
parents are messing up I have an 8 and
12 year old they want nothing more that
they become YouTube stars because that's
their generations movie star I made a
couple YouTube videos and they had
begged me to be in them and I've told
them no I would argue that many AO C's
mom's failure is not in putting the idea
in her head but by not protecting her
from entering the public arena before
she's old enough to even form her own
opinions appreciate your show and your
opinions on issues so I don't think you
do disagree that's how I mean we're in
agreement basically the basic point here
is that we shouldn't be we should be
using our kids to make political points
we should be turning our kids into viral
stars at all especially not in a
political context because then you're
you're guaranteeing that there's going
to be even more hatred and violence
coming their way and you're just you're
throwing them into a very volatile
situation on top of all the other
problems with doing that so I think we
agree with that I guess the only thing
you're disagreeing with is I said that
no eight-year-old naturally wants to be
a viral video star and what you're
saying is well some eight-year-olds
actually do want that but as parents
we're supposed to of course tell them no
because we're the parents maybe you're
right about that look you know Mike I
don't have any eight year old as I said
my oldest or six years old and there is
a significant difference between a six
year old and a year old I can't say that
my six year olds the idea thing of viral
stars like not even on their radar they
wouldn't even know what that means
maybe at eight it becomes a little bit
more on a kid's radar but I will say
that certainly too with this girl how
she's a essentially a political satirist
I can tell you no eight-year-old it
wants that I mean no eight-year-old even
knows what political satire is or
understands it okay there's just I'm
sorry there's no eight-year-old smart
enough to understand political satire
most adults don't understand it III
write satirical pieces myself and the
majority of adults are these days are
too stupid to understand satire when
they see it
kids even if they're not stupid but very
smart which I'm sure this girl's very
smart girl um
at eight year old eight years old they
just don't they don't they don't they
don't get it they don't understand it so
she doesn't understand what she's doing
she doesn't get the humor herself she
can't she's eight all right
from Brandon Matt I love the show my
question was regarding religion I've
always been a Christian by default as
I've never grown up practicing religion
but my family would go to church on
special occasions my question is do you
take all stories in the Bible literally
I've been having issues with my faith
because I want to believe all of it but
I have trouble when it comes to fully
believing stories that involve talking
snakes well you're gonna get me in
trouble
Brandon and we've we've talked about
this in the past my view on it is not a
secret although I guess if you didn't
watch the show months ago maybe it is I
don't well let's establish a couple
things first of all nobody takes the
entire Bible literally that would not
make sense to say the oh yeah I take it
all literally well what what does that
mean I mean because there there are
things in the Bible the Bible is a
collection of many different books of
many different genres they're not all
the same genre the entire Bible is not
just a story there are you know there
are Psalms
there are lamentations there's the
wisdom literature you know there's
there's exhortation there are epistles
there are you know teachings
Commandments I mean there are all kinds
of things like that which don't really
qualify as stories in my mind and among
those things now something like a
commandment a direct instruction where
God is saying do this don't do that well
then yeah we take that literally that's
that's the perfect example of a thing
you do take literally right but
something like a psalm I mean what does
it mean to take the Psalms literally
well nobody does it doesn't make any
sense it's poetry you by definition you
don't take poetry literally there's
truth there so you do get at the truth
but when you're taught when you're
reading if you read Poe
tree literally you're reading it like a
robot and then if there's a if there's a
metaphor or something or or imagery it's
like you're you try to take it literally
then you're not you're just not reading
it like a human being Jesus tells
parables of course we're gonna take the
parables literally in the sense that
when Jesus tells a certain parable
whether it's about the prodigal son or
any other parable or the you know the
Good Samaritan he's not trying to say
that this thing this event actually
happened like there really was a
prodigal son but there's a point to the
story a message that were meant to
understand so that's the first thing and
then related to that we just when we're
looking at any particular part of the
Bible or any particular story or passage
in the Bible if we want to understand
how we are to take it or read it then
the first thing we have to do is figure
out what genre is it so as I said the
parables genre that's a whole genre so
we read a parable we know and we
recognize okay this is a parable we
don't take it literally we are looking
for truth we're looking for a message
we're not taking it literally we
recommend we read the Psalms what genre
well this is this is poetry okay that's
the genre the question then is the book
of Genesis what genre is it what is
what's the genre that's the question now
I'll tell you the answer to that
question I can't tell you for sure I
don't know that's that's the that's
that's my answer I don't know exactly
I'm not going to pretend that I can sit
here and tell you with 100% certainty
how we are to read every part of the
Bible I'm not gonna tell you that I
understand every part of the Bible I
don't the book of Revelation a pie oh
that's a it's a whole genre I forget
about apocalyptic literature okay
there's another great example of a genre
that we don't take literally now the
book of Revelation there that's
obviously there's there's truth there
there's a message we're meant to
understand the message were meant to
take away from it but you
of course you don't read revelation
totally literally I don't you know most
adult Christians who are grownups don't
actually expect that literal horsemen
you know guys on horses are gonna come
out of the sky that is there be no
reason for that it would it would be you
know that would be God sort of be like
theatrics I just would what why did why
do you have if you have beings in the
sky why do they need to be on horses
it just it would be just you know
theatrical which there's no reason to
think that that's literally what's going
to happen but the horsemen are meant to
represent something so we're supposed to
understand what they represent and it's
being communicated to us using this sort
of imagery because it makes us it sticks
in our mind more and also I think
because with something like apocalyptic
literature at the end of the world you
so these are concepts that are beyond us
anyway and so if if if the Holy Spirit
were to inspire someone to write about
the end of the world in a totally
literal way we wouldn't understand it
would be total nonsense to us because
it's beyond us and so instead it's
especially when we're dealing with
concepts that are beyond our
comprehension that is especially when
imagery and parable and and metaphor and
all that's especially when those come
into play and I think that's why Jesus
used parables a lot because as Jesus he
knew knows that that we are very limited
in our cognitive abilities and so he
uses he expresses these ideas in a way
that we will understand and also a way
that will just stick with us again the
story of the prodigal son that's a story
everyone remembers if Jesus had just
said in a very literal way hey listen if
you if you go out in your sin and you
stop saying gee God will forgive you if
you just and he did say that in a
literal way many times but all the times
that he said it literally the thing that
that we all remember the most is that
story because that's just how we are
that's how our minds work so we think
whether John rrah
going back I'm battling what what is
what's the genre of Janice
well that's the question my answer ganas
I don't know exactly I can but but I
think that the answer probably is that
that Genesis is not a especially the
first few chapters of Genesis the
creation creation account it's not
literal and I mean I've done a whole
show on this you can go back and watch
that show there are many reasons why I
think that one of those reasons not the
only reason but one of those reasons is
that when we look at the science it's
just we know we know for a fact that
that is not how that is not literally
how the world came about just like there
are passages in the Bible which in a
literal sense seem to indicate that the
the earth that the Sun orbits the earth
there are passages there several
passages of the Bible which if you read
literally that's what would seem to
indicate there are also passages that
would seem to indicate literally that
the earth is flat now we know that that
is not true that that's not the way it
is and so we have to interpret those
Bible passages with the the reality of
the situation in mind in light of
reality we have to interpret those
passages there was a time when a lot of
people didn't know that the Earth orbits
the Sun and so they read those passages
and they thought that those passages you
know affirm the truth that the Sun
orbits the earth once it became clear
that that's not the case
we had to go back and say okay well I
guess we were wrong with our
interpretation of those passages we
can't cling to our old interpretation
when the realities are right in front of
us it's just you can't get around it so
to speak
pun intended so I think it's the same
thing with with the creation account
it's just the the seven-day 6,000 year
old earth it's just the science of sorry
the science doesn't work and I there are
I know there there are supposed
Christian scientific authorities who are
not authorities who will claim otherwise
and they'll throw a lot of statistics
and facts out at you but they're they're
just they're it's not true doesn't work
so that's how I would look at that all
right and I can look forward now to
many angry emails from Jacob this says
hey Matt I'm a student at Utah State
University and because I'm getting
closer to graduation there are some
upper-level classes I have to take
certain attributes we're taking a class
called perspectives on race because it
fulfills two attributes in a single
class which is nice however this week we
were given an assignment called the
privilege activity where we are asked a
series of questions and based on our
answers we will tell us how privileged
we are compared to our classmates along
with the activity we were given a blog
to read about white males and how white
males have it the easiest of all people
because of their supposed privilege I'm
not mean or vile or even that big of an
idiot but more and more I'm trying to
understand why my status as being white
and male and straight has made me the
enemy of all people just wondering about
your thoughts on this and hope that you
get a chuckle reading the questions I
could say I did a chuckle out of that
it's more just Jacob I you know you your
spy don't know how much money you're
spending going to Utah State University
and I'm not saying you're wasting your
money I mean hopefully you have a plan
and you'll go out and use that degree
I'm sure you will a lot of people do but
I mean if I was you I'm sure it already
does but it would tick me off that I'm
paying all this money to go to this
school and this is what you're wasting
my time with a privileged activity I'm
reading a blog by some what by some
liberal to lecture me about race me this
is what your way like this this useless
propaganda okay give me useful
information this this doesn't count so
it's just a total waste of money and it
is also a lie of course and so it takes
me off and we will leave it there hope
you guys have a great 4th of July
god bless america and Godspeed
hey everybody its Andrew Clavin host of
the Andrew Clavin show here is a
surprising thing the left virtually owns
all the most powerful means of
communication and they're using that to
constantly sell sexual malfeasance
racial division and self lacerating
anti-americanism you would think at this
point the public would be utterly
convinced but instead people are
beginning to turn away this is a great
time for conservatives to offer a 21st
century version of the founding ideals
of life liberty and the pursuit of
happiness we'll talk about it on the
Andrew Klavan show I'm Andrew Clavin